she might be the ghost at the
government's Feast but there's no
denying Liz truss's appeal from any
conservative party members this was the
buzziest event of the Tory conference so
far
standing room only at the back with
plenty more shut outside all packed in
to hear from the woman whose unfunded
tax cuts almost crashed the UK economy
last year and brought her Premiership to
a screeching halt after just 49 days
she's still banging the drum for those
tax cuts though we need businesses to be
able to ex
create new ideas
that's why I'm calling upon the
chancellor at the Autumn statement to
put Corporation back tax back down to 19
and frankly if we can get it lower the
better music to the years of those who
flocked here I don't vote conservative
to pay more tax and have the government
Banning and taking things away from me
so do you think that she is right that
the government should be cutting taxes
right now
um
I think that
they should look at it
while Rishi sunak and his Finance
Minister Jeremy Hunt say this is what
they've done and the answer is no
pre-election tax cuts are virtually
impossible hunt says his priority is
taming inflation the plan is working and
now we must see it through just as
Margaret Thatcher did many years ago
conference when we halve inflation
that's not a one percent income tax cut
it's a five percent boost to incomes
compared to if it stayed the same
but this is a significant ideological
split at the heart of the conservatives
conference is a chance for NPS and
conservative party members to mingle but
this year it's also a reminder of their
differences and a reminder that in that
leadership contest between Rishi sunak
and Liz truss the members did not choose
the current prime minister Rory
challenge Al Jazeera Manchester UK
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera